Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
I'M GONNA BE HONEST WITH YOU.
OUR SALES SUCK.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
MMM. IT'S YUMMY.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'M GONNA MAKE AN OFFER
OF $150,000 FOR 20%.
WOW.
WHOA!
HOLD IT, HOLD IT, HOLD IT.
I MADE A MISTAKE.
[ LAUGHS ]
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WAIT, WAIT, LET ME --
WAIT, WAIT,
LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT IT.
I'VE GOT AN OFFER.
LET ME DO IT.
LET ME MAKE AN OFFER.
NO. I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
A SWEETER DEAL THAN LORI,
WHO'S BEING
A LITTLE CHEAP TODAY.
DON'T BE RUDE.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
YOU'RE OUT OF YOUR MIND.
YOU'RE DELUSIONAL.
OH, BOY.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT
FROM WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK ARE MOMS
WITH A SWEET WAY
TO CLEAN UP MESSY KIDS.
HI.
I'M DANIELLE STANGLER.
AND HI.
I'M JULIA ROSSI.
AND WE ARE
FROM CASTLE ROCK, COLORADO,
AND WE ARE THE CREATORS
OF NeatCheeks.
WE ARE SEEKING $150,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
KIDS ARE GONNA GET MESSY,
BUT THE CLEANUP PROCESS
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
UNTIL NOW, PARENTS HAVE BEEN
USING TYPICAL WIPES
TO CLEAN THEIR KIDS'
FACES AND HANDS,
AND THEIR KIDS
ARE PUTTING UP A FIGHT.
THIS IS WHAT A TYPICAL
CLEANUP BATTLE LOOKS LIKE.
[ SQUEALING, CRYING ]
Corcoran: AWW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ SCREAMS ]
WHOA.
KEVIN'S NEVER GONNA CHANGE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WITH NeatCheeks, CLEANUP
IS EASY AND TANTRUM-FREE.
OUR WIPES ARE PLUSH,
MOISTURIZING, AND MILDLY SWEET.
THEY'RE PREFERRED
BY MOMS AND KIDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE GENTLE
ON SENSITIVE SKIN,
ALL-NATURAL, EFFECTIVE,
AND BEST OF ALL, THEY HAVE
A SWEET, PLEASANT FLAVOR.
THAT'S RIGHT -- FLAVOR!
FLAVOR!
LOOK HOW HAPPY NeatCheeks MAKES
KIDS DURING MEALTIME CLEANUP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban:
YOU GOT TO FEED THAT KID.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE SWEETEN OUR WIPES
WITH STEVIA,
WHICH IS
A NATURAL PLANT EXTRACT.
IT'S NOT SUGAR,
SO THERE'S NO STICKY RESIDUE
LEFT ON THEIR SKIN.
INSTEAD,
WHAT THEY CAN EXPECT
IS A PLEASANT, SWEET FLAVOR
ON THEIR LIPS
AND A HUGE SMILE ON THEIR FACE
WITH EVERY WIPE.
LET'S LET KIDS EVERYWHERE GET
MESSY WITHOUT FEAR OF CLEANUP.
WHY DON'T ALL OF YOU SHARKS
GET READY TO...
WIPE ON A SMILE WITH US?
WIPE ON A SMILE WITH US.
WE WANT YOU TO EXPERIENCE
THE NeatCheeks DIFFERENCE.
WE HAVE SAMPLES
FOR YOU TO TRY.
NOW,
AS YOU OPEN YOUR PACK,
IT IS COMPLETELY NORMAL
TO SMELL IT FIRST.
WE ARE CONDITIONED
TO DO THAT
'CAUSE MOST WIPES ARE
FRAGRANCED, VERSUS FLAVOR.
BUT WHAT YOU CAN ANTICIPATE
WITH OUR WIPES
IS A PLEASANT,
SWEET FLAVOR.
MMM. IT'S YUMMY.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH IT?
SO, I WAS AT A RESTAURANT
WITH MY FAMILY.
I DIDN'T HAVE
MY TYPICAL WIPES,
AND MY 18-MONTH-OLD
WAS COVERED IN MAC AND CHEESE.
WE WERE IN A QUIET RESTAURANT,
SO I KNEW IF I WIPED HER FACE,
SHE WOULD FUSS,
SO I ASKED MY HUSBAND
TO DIP HIS NAPKIN IN HIS WATER,
AND I BEGAN TO WIPE HER FACE,
AND SHE REACTED DIFFERENTLY.
SHE STARTED SAYING,
"NUMMY. MORE,"
BECAUSE IT WASN'T WATER
IN MY HUSBAND'S CUP --
IT WAS LEMONADE.
SO THAT'S WHEN THE IDEA OF
A FLAVORED FACE WIPE WAS BORN.
O'Leary: THAT'S FANTASTIC.
HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE?
YEAH, SO, WE ARE
CURRENTLY APPROACHING
ALMOST 40
RETAIL LOCATIONS.
TWO OF THOSE LOCATIONS
ARE WALGREENS,
IN WHICH WE HAD
A 90-DAY TEST.
HOW DID IT DO
ON THE TEST?
WE ACTUALLY HAD A RAPID REORDER
WITHIN 30 DAYS.
OUR GOAL
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
IS TO ROLL OUT REGIONALLY
WITH WALGREENS.
ALL RIGHT, SO, TELL US --
WHAT'S YOUR MARGINS, ET CETERA?
SO, WE MAKE IT
FOR 72 CENTS.
AND WHAT DO THEY
SELL IT FOR?
$3.99.
THAT'S PRICY.
W--WHAT -- THAT SOUNDS LIKE
A LOT FOR A WIPE.
WHAT IS THE COST
OF REGULAR WIPES?
THEY CAN GO AS LOW
AS $1.99.
OUCH.
IT SEEMS TO ME, THOUGH,
THAT YOU COULD PROBABLY
GET THIS PRICE DOWN.
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS BASED ON
LOW-VOLUME PRODUCTION,
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO BRING
THE PRICE DOWN
AT THE LARGER VOLUME...
TO WHAT?
...TO 53 CENTS.
THAT STILL DOESN'T LET YOU
MATCH AN EXISTING WIPE.
WE ARE
A PREMIUM-PRICE PRODUCT,
BUT WE ARE NOT THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PRODUCT ON THE MARKET.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE.
IN THIS PACKAGE, AS A PARENT,
YOU GET 12 HAPPY EXPERIENCES...
JUST LIKE
AN ICE-CREAM CONE.
...WHEN YOU WIPE
THEIR FACE.
YOU KNOW, THIS TRULY
SOLVES A PROBLEM.
Stangler:
AND WE ARE THE MARKET.
WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF SIX KIDS COMBINED,
SO THROUGH THIS PROCESS,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP,
FINE-TUNE, AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BRINGING
THE BEST PRODUCT TO THE MARKET.
SO, WHAT ARE SALES
THIS YEAR?
THIS YEAR,
WE ARE AT $4,000 IN SALES.
$4,000?!
HOW MUCH ARE YOU GONNA SELL
THIS YEAR, YOU THINK?
YEAH, SO, WE'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT
$90,000 TO $100,000 IN REVENUE,
BASED ON LAUNCHING TO
THE LARGEST TRADE SHOW INDUSTRY
IN SEPTEMBER.
WHEN YOU GO TO THAT SHOW
AND EVERYBODY SEES
THE STEVIA-INFUSED
NeatCheeks...
YES.
...INCLUDING
SOME OF YOUR COMPETITORS,
WHO ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER
THAN YOU,
THAT HAVE COST ADVANTAGE
ON SCALE...
YEAH, SURE.
...WHAT STOPS THEM FROM
PUTTING STEVIA IN THEIR WIPE?
SO, WE HAVE A PENDING PATENT
ON OUR PRODUCT.
LOOK, I THINK
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING IDEA.
I LOVE IDEAS THAT ARE BORN
OUT OF NECESSITY.
THAT'S FANTASTIC.
YEAH. THANK YOU.
NOW, THE PROBLEM I SEE
AS AN INVESTOR
IS YOU HAVE A GREAT IDEA,
BUT YOU ARE COCKROACHES
IN THE FACE-WIPE BUSINESS.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO
TO A TRADE SHOW
AND EXPOSE THIS
TO EVERY COMPETITOR,
AND IF IT TAKES OFF,
THE ONLY THING THAT HOLDS THEM
BACK FROM CRUSHING YOU
LIKE THE COCKROACHES YOU ARE
IS THE PATENT.
SO, TO ME, HAD YOU COME HERE
WITH A PATENT,
I WOULD HAVE LOOKED AT IT
AND SAID, "ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA HELP
THESE TWO LADIES,"
BUT I CAN'T DO THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
THE OUTCOME OF THE PATENT.
I'M OUT.
YOU GUYS, IT'S YOUR DREAM,
AND I GET THAT, RIGHT?
FOR ME,
IT'S ABOUT MAKING MONEY.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES
TO HELP YOU TRANSITION
FROM WHERE YOU ARE
TO A REAL COMPANY --
THAT'S A LOT OF TIME.
YOU'RE JUST TOO EARLY.
I'M OUT.
JULIA, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE $150,000?
YEAH, SO, THE $150,000
WILL ALLOW US
TO GO FULL TIME
IN THE BUSINESS.
WE STILL HAVE HOUSEHOLDS
TO MAINTAIN,
AND SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A SMALL PORTION
TO PAY OURSELVES SOMETHING
IN ORDER FOR US --
HOW MUCH IS "SOMETHING"?
$50,000.
EACH?
TOTAL, OR --
EACH. YEP, EACH.
SO YOU KNOW, I HATE YOUR ANSWER
TO WHY YOU NEED THE MONEY.
WHEN YOU START A BUSINESS,
YOU DON'T PAY YOURSELF.
YOU PAY THE BUSINESS FIRST.
CORRECT.
THE BUSINESS IS
A LIVING, BREATHING THING.
MM-HMM.
IT GETS EVERY PIECE OF FOOD,
EVERY DROP OF WATER.
CORRECT.
YEAH.
IT NEEDS TO SURVIVE
BEFORE YOU SURVIVE.
YEAH.
I'M OUT.
I TOTALLY APPRECIATE THAT,
AND THE THING IS,
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR FOUR YEARS.
WE HAVE SUPPORTIVE FAMILIES
THAT ALLOW IT TO PUSH FORWARD.
SO I'M TO THE POINT NOW THAT I
GET A JOB WITH ANOTHER COMPANY.
I'M GONNA SUGGEST TO YOU
THAT YOU DO THAT,
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY.
I REMEMBER WHEN I HAD ALMOST
600 SALESPEOPLE WORKING FOR ME.
I WAS A BIG BOSS,
THE BIG SHOT IN MY TOWN.
BY ANYONE'S STANDARD,
I WAS A SUCCESS,
BUT I KNEW
I WAS GOING BANKRUPT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I DID?
I WENT OUT
AND TOOK A FULL-TIME JOB
WHILE I WORKED
MY BUSINESS.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH STEPPING BACK
BEFORE YOU GO FORWARD.
RIGHT.
Herjavec: BUT, BARBARA,
WHAT ABOUT THEIR FAMILY?
YOU COULD FIGURE IT OUT.
WOMEN IN AMERICA
FIGURE IT OUT EVERY DAY.
I'M EIGHT MONTHS PREGNANT
AND GETTING
FOUR HOURS OF SLEEP AT NIGHT,
DOING EVERY SINGLE THING
IT TAKES,
AND IT'S NO JOKE
WHEN WE SAY
WE BARELY SLEEP,
'CAUSE WE ARE MANAGING BOTH.
I BELIEVE YOU.
NO, I GET IT,
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT THIS,
I THINK ONE THING
AND ONE THING ONLY --
"WILL THEY GET
THEIR PATENT?"
SO I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER
CONTINGENT ON YOU
GETTING THE PATENT, OKAY?
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 30%.
I THINK WE NEED TO HIT
BUY BUY BABY, TOYS "R" US.
I HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH A LOT
OF THE MAJOR STORES OUT THERE
THAT I THINK
WOULD CARRY THIS PRODUCT.
BUT I'D LIKE TO MOVE FAST.
'CAUSE I JUST THOUGHT
OF AN ANGLE ON THIS
THAT I THINK IT'S MISSING.
CAN YOU MAKE
A CHERRY FLAVOR?
YEAH.
THEN I'M GONNA MAKE AN OFFER
CONTINGENT ON ONLY ONE THING.
I'M GONNA MAKE IT BASED ON
YOU MAKING A CHERRY FLAVOR.
AND I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
A SWEETER DEAL THAN LORI,
WHO'S BEING A LITTLE CHEAP
TODAY, ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA MAKE AN OFFER
OF $150,000 FOR 20%.
Cuban:
JUST WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
WOW.
WHOA! HOLD IT,
HOLD IT, HOLD IT.
I MADE A MISTAKE.
[ LAUGHS ]
SHOCKING.
I'M GONNA MAKE AN OFFER
OF $150,000 FOR 25%.
OKAY. THE REASON --
Greiner: WELL, HERE, LET ME
CHANGE SOMETHING FOR YOU,
'CAUSE I REALLY
BELIEVE IN YOU.
WHAT'S THE NEW DEAL?
I'M GOING TO OFFER YOU
$150,000 FOR 25%, AS WELL,
CONTINGENT ON THE PATENT.
WE DO VALUE YOU AND YOUR
RESOURCES AND YOUR EXPERTISE,
ESPECIALLY IN
THE PATENT WORLD.
IS IT HARD CONTINGENCY
ON THE PATENT?
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NO CONCERN THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET IT APPROVED,
BASED ON --
Greiner:
I WILL PUT THIS WAY.
IF EVERYTHING THAT YOU TOLD ME
IS SO, I'M GOOD.
I'LL PULL THE CONTINGENCY
ON THE PATENT,
BECAUSE I'M TRUSTING YOU
THAT YOU SAY IT'S COMING.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT,
BUT DANIELLE AND JULIA
HAVE OFFERS
FROM BOTH LORI AND BARBARA
FOR THEIR FLAVORED BABY WIPES,
NeatCheeks.
IF EVERYTHING THAT YOU TOLD ME
IS SO, I'M GOOD.
I'LL PULL THE CONTINGENCY
ON THE PATENT,
BECAUSE I'M TRUSTING YOU
THAT YOU SAY IT'S COMING.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT I BRING
TO THE TABLE THAT'S NOT JUST ME.
WHAT I BRING TO THE TABLE
IS I BRING
ALL MY OTHER ENTREPRENEURS.
THEY ALL LOVE EACH OTHER.
THEY KNOW EACH OTHER
ON A FIRST-NAME BASIS.
THEY TALK A FEW TIMES A WEEK.
THEY HELP EACH OTHER.
THEY SHARE RESOURCES.
WHAT YOU GET
BY COMING INTO MY CAMP
IS YOU JOIN
OUR HAPPY LITTLE FAMILY.
AND IT'S A HAPPY FAMILY.
Herjavec: YOU HAVE 5√ KIDS.
YOU DON'T NEED MORE COMPANY.
Greiner: YOU KNOW WHAT?
O'Leary: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
DON'T START AGAIN.
NOT TO TAKE ANYTHING --
NO, NOT TO TAKE ANYTHING AWAY,
BUT I DO HAVE TO ADD THIS...
LADIES, LADIES, YOU HAVE --
YOU HAVE TO -- WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
WAIT, KEVIN.
I HAVE TO ADD THIS.
YOU H-- NO, YOU DON'T.
...BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S ONLY FAIR.
NO, YOU DON'T!
MY ENTREPRENEURS
ARE ALSO A FAMILY.
THEY ALL KNOW EACH OTHER
BECAUSE WE ALL GET TOGETHER,
AND THEY'RE IN MY SHOW
ON QVC TOGETHER.
♪ KUMBAYA, KUMBAYA ♪
CALL ANY OF THEM.
WAIT.
I OFTEN GET MINE
TO SING TOGETHER AROUND A FIRE.
ALL MY ENTREPRENEURS
GET TOGETHER EVERY MONTH.
MY ENTREPRENEURS SING.
[ LAUGHS ]
EVERY MONTH! AMAZING!
MAKE UP YOUR MIND!
THEY'RE ON QVC.
AY-YI-YI.
DON'T BE RUDE.
THEY ARE IN MY SHOW TOGETHER,
SO THEY'RE ALL WORKING TOGETHER,
AND THEY'RE
ONE BIG, HAPPY FAMILY.
MY FiberFix, SCRUB DADDY,
DROP STOP.
STOP.
AND SEVERAL OF THEM MAKE
PACKAGING FOR EACH OTHER.
I HAVE ALL MY ENTREPRENEURS
TO MY DINNER TABLE
WITH MY CHILDREN.
STOP! STOP!
WAIT. WAIT, WAIT.
STOP!
COME ON, GIRLS, LET'S GO.
CHOP-CHOP. LET'S GO.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
WE APPRECIATE
ALL OFFERS,
UM, AND I THINK
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
IS TAKE BARBARA'S OFFER.
I THINK YOU MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
UH-HUH. UH-HUH.
I'M NOT A SORE LOSER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
DON'T GLOAT. DON'T GLOAT.
ALL RIGHT, I WON'T GLOAT.
DON'T GLOAT.
I'M SO SORRY, LORI.
DON'T BE A SORE WINNER.
NO, IT'S OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M HAPPY YOU GUYS
MADE A DEAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU!
THANK YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M SO EXCITED.
GOOD JOB. GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BARBARA AND LORI
ARE BOTH AMAZING,
BUT WE JUST FELT LIKE
BARBARA, I THINK,
WAS MORE ALIGNED WITH
OUR STRATEGIC OBJECTIVES
MOVING FORWARD,
AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHERE
SHE CAN HELP US TAKE THE BRAND.
Narrator:
EARLIER THIS SEASON,
WE SAW DAYMOND JOHN MAKE A DEAL
WITH SUN-STACHES,
A NOVELTY-SUNGLASSES COMPANY.
WE WANT TO GROW TO
MORE LICENSING -- MARVEL, DC.
John: I CAN HELP YOU
GET THE LICENSES YOU NEED,
AND THAT WILL SAVE YOU
A LOT OF MONEY.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
WHAT'S UP?
HEY, HEY, WHAT'S UP?
Man: THIS HAS BEEN AMAZING,
PARTNERING WITH DAYMOND.
IT'S BEEN LESS THAN
FIVE MONTHS,
AND WE'VE ALREADY SOLD
$4.1 MILLION.
GUYS, THIS IS MARVEL.
YOU READY?
LET'S GO.
John: AS SOON AS
WE DID OUR DEAL,
I CALLED MY FRIENDS AT MARVEL
AND SECURED A LICENSING DEAL
FOR SUN-STACHES.
PAUL!
DAYMOND,
HOW ARE YOU?
MARVEL IS ONE
OF THE WORLD'S MOST PROMINENT
CHARACTER-BASED
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANIES.
THEY HAVE A LIBRARY
OF MORE THAN 8,000 CHARACTERS.
THAT MEANS A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUN-STACHES.
WE ACTUALLY BROUGHT THE FIRST
SET OF MARVEL SUN-STACHES
TO SHOW YOU GUYS.
THE WAY THE DEAL WORKS
IS WE DESIGN,
MANUFACTURE,
AND SELL TO RETAILERS,
AND WE PAY MARVEL A ROYALTY
ON ALL THAT WE SELL.
THESE ARE GREAT, GUYS.
THESE ARE REALLY EXCELLENT.
MARVEL IS OWNED
BY THE WALT DISNEY COMPANY,
SO THE SYNERGY THAT WE CAN BUILD
BETWEEN OUR BRANDS IS LIMITLESS.
I DON'T EVEN NEED
TO WISH YOU GUYS LUCK.
YOU'RE IN GOOD HANDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Man:
SMALL COMPANIES LIKE OURS
DON'T JUST MAKE DEALS
WITH DISNEY.
WE TRIED TO GET
A DEAL WITH MARVEL
BEFORE WE WENT ON "SHARK TANK,"
AND WE GOT TURNED DOWN.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY.
Man: "SHARK TANK" HAS CHANGED
OUR ENTIRE BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT JUST OUR BRAND.
IT'S SUN-STACHES
ALONGSIDE MARVEL.
IT'S AMAZING.
GREAT JOB.
John: I'M EXCITED TO BE PART
OF THIS RIDE, AS WELL.
THIS IS THE POWER
OF "SHARK TANK."
THIS IS ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AT ITS BEST.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS AN INNOVATION
TO MAKE A DANGEROUS JOB
MUCH SAFER.
HI, I'M MARK MELNI,
AND I'M THE INVENTOR
OF THE MELNI CONNECTOR.
AND I'M ARMAND ECKERT.
I'M THE CFO.
I'M BYRON DUNN. I'M THE GUY
WHO KEEPS THE LIGHTS ON.
SHARKS, WE'RE ASKING
FOR $500,000
FOR A 5% EQUITY INTEREST
IN OUR COMPANY.
Melni: MY INVENTION'S
GOING TO COMPLETELY CHANGE
THE ELECTRICAL INDUSTRY.
LET ME SHOW YOU
WHAT IT'S GONNA CHANGE.
IT HASN'T CHANGED IT YET,
YET IT'S WORTH $10 MILLION?
ABSOLUTELY.
I HOPE BAD THINGS
DON'T HAPPEN TO YOU.
OKAY.
I'VE BEEN A LINEMAN IN THE POWER
INDUSTRY FOR OVER 30 YEARS.
IN THAT TIME,
I'VE PUT ON THOUSANDS
OF THESE COMPRESSION CONNECTORS,
ALSO KNOWN AS
A CRIMP CONNECTOR.
WHAT I'M GOING TO DO NOW
IS SHOW YOU HOW TO MAKE
AN ELECTRICAL CONNECTION
USING THE CURRENT TECHNOLOGY.
ANYTIME YOU HAVE
THE END OF A WIRE,
YOU HAVE TO PUT SOME SORT
OF CONNECTOR OR TERMINATOR ON IT
TO MAKE IT UP.
SO WHAT YOU DO -- YOU PUT
THAT IN THERE, THAT IN THERE.
THIS IS CALLED A CRIMPER,
AND WHAT IT DOES --
IT CRUSHES THE CONNECTOR
DOWN ONTO THE WIRE
WITH A FEW THOUSAND POUNDS
OF FORCE.
[ GRUNTS ]
OOH.
[ SNAP ]
BET YOU HAD A LOT OF FUN
DOING THAT FOR 30 YEARS.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
LOT OF SHOULDER INJURIES.
YEAH.
IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS UP COMPLETELY,
WE'D HAVE TO DO
FIVE MORE CRIMPS ON THERE.
UNDER NORMAL CONDITIONS,
IT TAKES YOU ABOUT 10 MINUTES
TO MAKE ONE CONNECTION.
OKAY, NOW LET'S SEE
THE BETTER WAY.
ALL RIGHT.
HE TOOK YOUR LINE.
EXCUSE ME, KEVIN,
YOU TOOK MY LINES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M HELPING YOU OUT HERE,
'CAUSE I'M TRYING TO GET TO
THAT $10 MILLION PLACE.
HERE'S THE MELNI --
HERE'S THE MELNI CONNECTOR.
YOU PUT THIS IN HERE,
THIS IN THERE.
SNUG IT UP
WITH YOUR HANDS.
THAT TIGHTENS IT DOWN,
AND IT'S DONE.
HERE'S WHAT
I REALLY WANT TO KNOW --
IS IT SAFER
DOING IT THE NEW WAY?
IT'S MUCH SAFER,
AND YOU JUST SAW THAT I DID THAT
IN PROBABLY 15 SECONDS.
I GET THAT,
BUT WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
OUR SALES --
Greiner:
AND WHO ARE YOU SELLING TO?
WELL, WE HAVE OUR FIRST
PURCHASE ORDER OF $585,000.
WE WERE CONTACTED
BY A COMPANY
CALLED IRRIGATION COMPONENTS
INTERNATIONAL.
THEY SELL THEM TO
THE IRRIGATION-PIVOT MARKET.
O'Leary: SO, YOU HA--
ALL RIGHT,
WALK ME THROUGH THIS.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU GONNA
SELL IT FOR?
SO, YOU H-- LISTEN.
HOW MUCH DOES IT
COST YOU TO MAKE?
OUR MANUFACTURING COST
FOR THAT SIZE IS $15.
$15. AND WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
SELL IT TO THESE PEOPLE FOR?
AND WE'RE GONNA SELL IT
TO THE WHOLESALER AT $39.
THIS IS AN INDUSTRIAL
APPLICATION, OKAY,
THAT MAYBE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL --
YET TO BE PROVEN.
YOU TOLD ME SO FAR,
AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
THE ONLY SALE YOU HAVE
IS A PURCHASE ORDER --
NOT FILLED YET --
FOR $500,000.
IS THAT RIGHT?
$585,000.
$585,000, YES.
YOU'RE OUT OF YOUR MINDS PUTTING
A $10 MILLION VALUE ON THIS.
Melni:
THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING.
THIS -- WE -- WE'RE ENTERING
THE MARKETPLACE
ON THE AGRICULTURAL
THROUGH THESE -- THESE PIVOTS.
BUT WHY AREN'T YOU
GOING AFTER THIS MARKET?
WE ARE. WE'RE SIMULTANEOUSLY
GOING AFTER --
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY ORDERS
FROM THIS MARKET?
NOT YET, NO.
[ GROANS ]
WE'VE MET WITH HOME DEPOT,
AND WE'VE MET WITH LOWE'S.
MARK, I THOUGHT YOU WERE
PROPOSING AN INDUSTRIAL SALE,
SO DID I.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE GOING DOWN
THE CONSUMER MARKET.
ALSO CONSUMER?
THE REAS--
LET'S BACK UP
FOR A SECOND.
PLEASE.
WE HAVE
MULTIPLE PRODUCTS.
THIS IS JUST ONE PRODUCT,
AND IT CROSSES MANY INDUSTRIES.
IT CROSS THE MILITARY.
IT CROSSES UTILITIES.
IT CROSSES RESIDENTIAL,
COMMERCIAL, INDUSTRIAL.
BUT, MARK, YOU CAME OUT TODAY
WITH THIS PRODUCT.
YES.
YEAH,
LIKE, I DIDN'T KNOW --
I THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS
TO BE BOUGHT BY, YOU KNOW,
THE STATES AND GOVERNMENT.
YEAH, YOU GUYS DIDN'T DO
A GOOD JOB
OF CONVEYING
THAT THERE'S A CONSUMER OPTION.
I NEED TO GET AWAY
FROM THE PRODUCT FOR A MINUTE.
I NEED A MENTAL BREAK.
HOW DID YOU TWO GUYS
GET TOGETHER?
I GOT TO TELL YOU
THE STORY, BARBARA.
WELL, PLEASE DO.
LET'S HEAR IT.
BYRON OWNS A MAGAZINE
IN COLORADO.
HE'S BEEN A 30-YEAR LINEMAN,
AND HE STARTED THE MAGAZINE.
WHAT MAGAZINE?
POWERLINEMAN MAGAZINE.
PERFECT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, I CALLED HIM UP, AND I SAID,
"THIS IS A NEW THING."
HE SAID, "SEND ME ONE.
LET ME SEE IT."
AND THEN HE INVESTED $50,000
IN THE PRODUCT.
WOW.
Dunn:
I'M NOT A BUSINESSMAN.
IT TOOK ME FIVE MINUTES
TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT WORKS,
AND AS A LINEMAN,
I WANTED IN.
BYRON, WHAT WAS THE
VALUE OF THE COMPANY
WHEN YOU PUT IN $50,000?
I NEVER ASKED.
BYRON,
WHY DID YOU TRUST HIM?
I DON'T TRUST HIM AT ALL.
IT'S THIS PRODUCT.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
IT'S -- IT'S --
IT'S WHAT IT IS, IS THIS --
BYRON, YOU ARE AWESOME.
WELL, THIS TAKES AWAY THIS.
THIS IS A KILLER.
O'Leary:
I LOOK AT IT AND SAY,
"LOOK, YOU MAY HAVE BUILT
A BETTER MOUSETRAP."
THERE'S A LOT
OF EVIDENCE HERE.
PARTICULARLY, YOU GOT A LINESMAN
TO PUT UP HIS MONEY
WITHOUT EVEN ASKING
WHAT THE VALUATION WAS.
THAT'S VERY --
THAT WAS POWERFUL.
THAT WAS THE MOST POWERFUL PART
OF YOUR PITCH.
IT'S A GREAT ENDORSEMENT.
Greiner: $50,000
IS A LOT OF MONEY.
NOW YOU HAVE THE CHALLENGE
OF EXECUTION.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO MANUFACTURE
AT AN ATTRACTIVE COST.
YOU HAVE TO DEFINE
WHICH MARKETS
AND WHAT TIMING
YOU'RE GONNA GO AFTER THEM IN.
YOU KNOW,
SELLING TO A UTILITY
IS FAR MORE CHALLENGING
IN TERMS OF TIMING,
VERSUS A CONSUMER PRODUCT
AT A LOWE'S, FOR EXAMPLE.
IT'S NOT WORTH $10 MILLION
TODAY -- NOT TO ME.
I'M OUT
WITH EXTREME PREJUDICE.
WHAT WE REALLY HAVEN'T GOT
A CONCEPT OF
IS HOW BIG
CAN YOUR SALES BE.
NOW, IF YOU'RE GONNA
SIT HERE AND SAY,
"IN A YEAR,
OUR SALES CAN BE $1 BILLION,"
$10 MILLION VALUATION
LOOKS CHEAP.
THE ELECTRICAL-INDUSTRY
CONNECTOR MARKET'S
A $50 BILLION MARKET.
WE'RE PROJECTING NEXT YEAR, OUR
SALES ARE GONNA BE $6 MILLION.
THAT'S 110,000 UNITS --
NOT VERY MANY.
AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR?
AND PROBABLY ABOUT $18 MILLION
AFTER THAT.
Corcoran: YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
COME INTO THE SHARK TANK
AND YOU MAKE
YOUR PRESENTATION,
I ALWAYS LIKE TO GET IT
REALLY FAST --
GET WHAT YOU'RE SELLING,
GET THE NUMBERS.
KIND OF THOUGHT
IT WAS ONE TOOL
WITH ONE APPLICATION
FOR THE INDUSTRIAL SPACE.
THEN I HEARD "CONSUMER."
I THINK YOU DIDN'T
COMMUNICATE THAT WELL AT ALL.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Greiner: I THINK IT SEEMS
LIKE A BETTER MOUSETRAP.
IT SEEMS REALLY SMART.
BUT WHAT SEEMS
REALLY DIFFICULT IS
HOW ARE YOU GONNA
GET IT OUT THERE,
AND HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO SELL IT?
AND I THINK THAT I'M NOT
THE RIGHT SHARK FOR THIS,
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
Herjavec:
LET ME TELL YOU WHERE I'M AT.
WHAT I LOVED
ABOUT YOUR PRESENTATION,
AND WHERE I REALLY HOPED
YOU WERE GOING,
WAS TO
THE INDUSTRIAL MARKET.
BYRON IS THE REAL DEAL.
I SEE THE APPLICATION.
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE THE USER
OF THE PRODUCT.
BUT...
WE WENT FROM BYRON...
TO IRRIGATION SYSTEMS...
TO HOME DEPOT.
YOU KNOW,
IN FAIRNESS, MARK,
I'M SURE YOU GUYS
ARE VERY NICE GUYS,
BUT IF BYRON
WASN'T STANDING THERE...
OH, BOY.
YEAH.
HOW LONG WOULD THIS PRESENTATION
HAVE BEEN?
OH, BOY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA TELL YOU
POINT-BLANK --
I DON'T KNOW THIS BUSINESS
AT ALL.
BUT I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WHEN I WAS STARTING
AudioNet,
WHICH TURNED INTO
THE STREAMING INDUSTRY,
BASICALLY,
I HAD PEOPLE COMING TO ME,
THROWING MONEY AT ME.
WE HAD ZERO IN SALES --
NOTHING.
NOT ONE PERSON UNDERSTOOD
WHAT WE WERE DOING.
YEAH.
THEY JUST KNEW, BASED OFF
OF WHAT WE WERE SHOWING THEM,
THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND SOMETHING BIG.
I BRAND THAT
"FOMO INVESTING."
YOU KNOW WHAT "FOMO"
STANDS FOR?
"FEAR OF MISSING OUT."
[ LAUGHTER ]
EVERYBODY THAT
YOU'VE COME IN CONTACT
HAS PUT THEIR MONEY
WHERE THEIR MOUTH IS.
MM-HMM, YES.
SO HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE 500K
FOR 12%,
AND I WANT AN OPTION TO PUT IN
ANOTHER MILLION DOLLARS
AT A $15 MILLION VALUATION,
MEANING IF YOU GROW AND THINGS
ARE GOING ACCORDING TO PLAN,
RIGHT, I GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUY MORE OF THE COMPANY.
WOW.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
MAY I --
MAY I MAKE A CALL?
OH, HELL NO.
YOU GUYS TAKE MY OFFER?
...TO DROP YOUR EQUITY
A LITTLE BIT?
...YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M JUST ADVISING YOU...
ABSOLUTELY, MARK.
THANK YOU.
DEAL.
Greiner: WHOO-HOO!
[ CHUCKLES ]
BYRON, YOU WERE WORRIED
ABOUT YOUR 50 GRAND.
SO GLAD HE DID THAT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
YOU'RE AWESOME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YEAH, GUYS.
THANKS, EVERYONE.
LET'S GO MAKE
WHATEVER THAT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S DO IT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANKS, GUYS.
BYE-BYE.
THANKS.
BYE.
BYRON!
LIFE IS GOOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
BYRON,
YOU ARE AMAZING.
Dunn: I DON'T EVEN
REALLY KNOW WHAT HAPPENED,
'CAUSE I'M NOT
A BUSINESSMAN,
BUT I KNOW
THAT CONNECTOR'S GOOD,
AND I KNOW THE LINEMEN
ARE GONNA LIKE IT,
SO I'M JUST VERY HAPPY.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A TECHNOLOGY FOR BOOK LOVERS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M SHERISSE HAWKINS.
AND I'M ALEX MILEWSKI.
WE ARE THE COFOUNDERS
OF BENEATH THE INK,
FROM BOULDER, COLORADO.
WE'RE SEEKING $350,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
WE'RE A DIGITAL-TEXT
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
THAT SPARKS
READER CURIOSITY.
WE DO THIS BY EMBEDDING
RICH CURATED CONTENT
BENEATH THE INK
OF E-BOOKS.
WHEN YOU'RE READING SOMETHING
AND IT PIQUES YOUR INTEREST,
WHAT DO YOU DO?
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT A CHARACTER
OR HOW TO PRONOUNCE THEIR NAME,
WHO CAN YOU TURN TO?
AT BENEATH THE INK,
WE MAKE ALL OF THIS POSSIBLE
IN A WAY
THAT'S AMAZINGLY HELPFUL,
BLISSFULLY FREE OF THE INTERNET,
AND ELEGANTLY UNOBTRUSIVE.
LET ME SHOW YOU.
YOU'RE RELAXING
IN A CHAIR,
READING ONE OF
YOUR FAVORITE BOOKS,
"BENEATH A MARBLE SKY."
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU COME ACROSS A NAME
THAT YOU'RE CURIOUS ABOUT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE READING
A BENEATH THE INK EDITION,
YOU CAN SIMPLY TOUCH ON
THE GLOWING WORD TO LEARN MORE.
NOW YOU CAN GET TO KNOW
THIS CHARACTER.
WE CALL THESE EXTRAS "BINKS,"
OR "BENEATH THE INK LINKS,"
AND BINKS CAN CONTAIN
ALMOST ANYTHING.
THIS IS A BINK WITH A PICTURE
FROM AN ACTUAL PLACE
MENTIONED IN THE BOOK.
MAYBE YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN WHERE SOMETHING IS.
THIS BINK HAS A MAP.
YOU CAN EVEN ZOOM IN
AND TAKE A LOOK AROUND.
THIS PANORAMIC BINK SERVES
AS A WINDOW TO THE TAJ MAHAL.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY TURN YOUR
DEVICE AND EXPLORE THE SCENE,
AS IF YOU WERE
REALLY THERE.
BENEATH THE INK IS POISED
TO CHANGE HOW WE READ
AND MAKE E-READING
MORE IMMERSIVE AND EXCITING.
JOIN US ON OUR JOURNEY
BENEATH THE INK.
IT HAS TO BE
A BINK-ENABLED BOOK, RIGHT?
SO YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH
AN ANNOTATION PROCESS
FOR EACH BOOK,
WHICH HAS GOT TO BE
TIME-CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE.
EXPLAIN THE WHOLE ANNOTATION
AND INTEGRATION PROCESS.
SO, THE PRODUCT IS
AN ONLINE PORTAL.
AS AN AUTHOR,
YOU GO INTO THE PORTAL,
YOU UPLOAD
YOUR MANUSCRIPT,
AND THEN YOU DRAG AND DROP
CONTENT --
SO YOU MAKE THE AUTHOR
DO IT?
YEAH, THE CONTENT OWNER
DOES THE CURATING.
SO NOW I'M THE CONSUMER.
I BUY THE KINDLE,
OR WHATEVER THE READER IS.
DO I THEN LOG ON AND DOWNLOAD
YOUR VERSION OF IT?
YEAH.
SO, THAT'S THE BEST PART.
AS THE AUTHOR,
AT THE CLICK OF A BUTTON,
YOU CAN GET A VERSION
FOR ALL OF THE MAJOR
DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS,
AND THEN, AS A READER,
I CAN GO TO MY FAVORITE CHANNEL.
SAY I'M ON
THE OLDEST KINDLE,
AND I CAN FIND
THE BENEATH THE INK EDITION
OF THAT BOOK
AND DOWNLOAD THAT.
AND WHERE DO YOU GET PAID?
THERE'S
THREE REVENUE STREAMS.
FIRST OF ALL,
WE HAVE A LICENSING MODEL
FOR LARGE CORPORATIONS
OR INSTITUTIONS THAT WANT TO DO
SEVERAL BENEATH TITLES.
WE ALSO HAVE
A SUBSCRIPTION MODEL.
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
HYBRID AUTHORS
OR SELF-PUBLISHED AUTHORS,
WE CHARGE $12 A MONTH
FOR THAT SUBSCRIPTION FEE.
AND THEN WE HAVE AN EXPORT FEE
THAT'S $199 PER CHANNEL.
SO, A TYPICAL BOOK
THAT IS GONNA GET BINKED
WOULD COST HOW MUCH
TO THE AUTHOR?
LESS THAN $1,000.
WE TAKE A ROYALTY SHARE
ON EACH TITLE SOLD,
AND THAT MEANS THAT
THE UP-FRONT COST FOR THE AUTHOR
CAN BE LESS, BECAUSE --
ALEX, WHO'S PAYING YOU
THAT ROYALTY?
SO, THAT COMES FROM
THE CONTENT OWNER,
FROM EITHER THE PUBLISHER
OR THE AUTHOR.
O'Leary:
I'VE GOT THREE BOOKS OUT,
SO I'M INTRIGUED.
LET'S SAY I'M $14.95
ON MY UNBINKED BOOK.
AM I STILL $14.95 ON MY BINK?
NO.
SO, WE'VE DONE TWO
INDEPENDENT FOCUS-GROUP TESTS.
WHAT WE ASK IS, "WOULD YOU
PAY MORE FOR THIS CONTENT?"
98% OF THE USERS SAID
THEY WOULD PAY 10% TO 20% MORE
FOR THAT ENHANCED VERSION.
SO THEY'D PAY ANOTHER $2?
RIGHT.
Cuban: SO, THEN, LET'S JUST
TALK ABOUT YOUR COMPANY.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
SO, WE CONSIDER OURSELVES
PRE-REVENUE...
OF COURSE YOU DO.
...WHICH IS VERY, VERY COMMON
FOR STARTUPS AT THIS STAGE.
HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN IN BUSINESS?
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR TWO YEARS,
SINCE ALEX AND I MET.
I BROUGHT THE TEAM TOGETHER
AND RAISED OUR FIRST ROUND
OF FUNDING THROUGH
A CONVERTIBLE NOTE.
HOW MUCH DID YOU RAISE?
$640,000.
WOW!
O'Leary:
THE REAL DEAL HERE IS
IF YOU CAN BECOME A BRAND
SUPPORTED BY PUBLISHERS SAYING,
"IF I'M GONNA PUT IT OUT
ELECTRONICALLY AS AN E-BOOK,
IT'S GOT TO BE BINK."
THAT'S THE VISION.
THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THIS THING'S
GONNA BE WORTH ANYTHING.
I DISAGREE.
WHY?
HYBRID AUTHORS
AND SELF-PUBLISHING AUTHORS
ARE EXPLODING.
HOW MANY TITLES
ARE BINKED RIGHT NOW?
WE HAVE EIGHT TITLES
THAT ARE BINKED RIGHT NOW.
Herjavec: THAT'S IT?
WE WENT AFTER
SPECIFIC KEY MARKETS.
FOR YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AT THIS,
YOU HAVE TO BECOME
UBIQUITOUS.
YOU NEED
HIGH-PROFILE BOOKS
FROM MAJOR AUTHORS
THAT WANT TO BE BINKED.
YES.
YOU GET A "HARRY POTTER,"
AS AN EXAMPLE, BINKED,
YOU'RE DONE.
YES.
WE RIDE THAT WAVE.
EVERYBODY ELSE
WILL COME TO YOU.
YES.
BECAUSE --
HAVE YOU APPROACHED
ANY PEOPLE LIKE --
LIKE LARGE PUBLISHERS,
AND --
YES, YES, YES.
SO WHERE ARE YOU WITH THAT?
WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
A THRILLER AUTHOR WHO IS BIG.
LOOK, WHAT WILL
MY INCREMENTAL SALES BE
TO OFFSET THE COST
OF DOING THAT?
YES.
THAT'S ALL I CARE ABOUT.
YOU TELL ME I BINK IT
AND I GET A 60% LIFT,
30% LIFT, 20% LIFT,
THEN I CAN MEASURE WHETHER IT'S
WORTH PAYING YOU IN PERPETUITY
OR ROYALTY.
I THINK
THE MODEL'S UNPROVEN YET.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT, GUYS,
I'M NOT THERE ON THIS.
YOU ARE AT THE VERY BEGINNING
OF A VERY ROCKY ROAD.
I'M OUT.
WE HAVE DE-RISKED
THIS BUSINESS...
[ Chuckling ] NO.
NO, YOU HAVEN'T.
...FROM THE TEAM TO THE MARKET
TO OUR REFERENCE ACCOUNTS.
YOU'RE DELUSIONAL.
YOU'VE RAISED $600,000.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO DRIVE DEMAND.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO PAY THE MAJOR AUTHORS
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO GET
PAID TO DO THE WORK
AND TO CONVERT THEIR VERSIONS
TO BINK.
DO YOU LIKE THE TECHNOLOGY
ENOUGH TO HELP US GET THERE?
NO.
I MEAN, I'M SURE
YOU'RE A BRILLIANT PROGRAMMER,
BUT I THINK YOU'VE TRIED
TO EXTEND TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S ALREADY THERE.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT, GUYS.
IT'LL TAKE MORE CASH THAN
I'D EVER BE WILLING TO APPLY.
I THINK
YOU'VE GOT COMPETITION
YOU DON'T EVEN REALIZE
THAT YOU HAVE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
Greiner:
I THINK IT SOUNDS REALLY SMART,
AND A MUCH BETTER
READING EXPERIENCE,
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
VERY COMPLICATED
FOR YOU TO BE ABLE
TO GET THAT OUT THERE
AND MAKE MONEY FROM IT.
I CAN'T INVEST. I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
I DON'T THINK YOU'LL FIND
A MORE TENACIOUS
AND DRIVEN GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
Corcoran:
I HAPPEN TO SEE THE MERIT IN IT.
I HAVE A VERY GOOD-SELLING BOOK
FOR 12 YEARS NOW.
I COULD PICTURE A MILLION SPOTS
WHERE I COULD HAVE A BINK
AND REALLY ENRICH
THE EXPERIENCE.
BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA MAKE YOU
A LOT OF MONEY.
I JUST DON'T HAVE THE FAITH
THAT THIS BUSINESS WILL WORK.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, WHO'S LEFT?
IT'S ME.
UH, ALEX,
I THINK IT'S, UH,
A BRILLIANT IDEA.
UM...I REALLY DO.
BUT, YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
IT SEEMS SO SELF-EVIDENT --
IT HAS TO DRIVE
MORE BOOK SALES.
BUT YOU DON'T SEEM TO
SHARE IN THAT WITH ME.
NO. WE ABSOLUTELY
SHARE THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
THE MONEY FOR.
WE NEED THE MONEY
FOR OUR GO-TO-MARKET STRATEGY
SO THAT WE CAN TEST
THAT HYPOTHESIS.
RIGHT, BUT YOU'RE SEARCHING
FOR A REVENUE MODEL. YOU ARE.
IT'S JUST TOO EARLY.
I JUST CAN'T GET BEHIND IT
RIGHT NOW.
AND FRANKLY, $350,000,
FOR THE WAY I SEE YOU HAVING TO
BUY YOUR WAY INTO THE MARKET --
IT'S JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
IT WOULD TAKE MILLIONS.
AND I'D BE INTERESTED
IF YOU HAD A VERY CLEAR PATH,
BUT YOU DON'T.
I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
Milewski: THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
Milewski: THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE WAY OF THE FUTURE.
WE CAN SEE IT AS CLEARLY
AS WE SAW THE SHARKS TODAY.
AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY MISSED OUT,
WE'RE STILL HEADING
IN THAT DIRECTION.
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE.
WE'RE GONNA BINK MORE BOOKS.
WE'RE GONNA WORK WITH
MORE AUTHORS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
THE GO-TO STANDARD
FOR ENHANCED BOOKS
IN THE FUTURE.
MY NAME IS MONT HANDLEY, AND I'M
FROM PITTSBURGH, PENNSYLVANIA.
MY PRODUCT IS PittMoss, AND IT'S
A REPLACEMENT FOR PEAT MOSS.
PEAT MOSS
IS A NATURAL SOIL ADDITIVE
THAT'S COMMONLY USED
BY HOME GARDENERS,
COMMERCIAL GREENHOUSES,
AND NURSERIES.
IT HELPS PLANTS RETAIN WATER
AND GROW FASTER.
THE PROBLEM
WITH HARVESTING PEAT MOSS --
IT HAS TERRIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES.
AND AS PEATLANDS AROUND
THE WORLD ARE BEING DRAINED,
THEY RELEASE
AS MUCH AS 1 BILLION TONS
OF CARBON POLLUTION
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE EVERY YEAR.
THAT IS NEARLY 8%
OF ALL ANNUAL CARBON POLLUTION.
IF WE DON'T START
CONSERVING PEATLANDS NOW,
OUR PLANET COULD BE
IN BIG TROUBLE.
BUT MY PRODUCT, PittMoss,
OFFERS A GREEN AND SUSTAINABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO PEAT MOSS.
IT'S MADE
FROM RECYCLED NEWSPAPER,
AND IT WOULD OTHERWISE END UP
IN A LANDFILL.
THIS BUSINESS
MEANS EVERYTHING TO ME.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE FINANCIAL SUCCESS.
IT'S ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
COLLECTIVELY GOOD
FOR THE PLANET.
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING A BUSINESS
AND REALIZING
YOU CAN STILL ACHIEVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I HOPE THE SHARKS SEE
THAT WHAT I'M DOING IS IMPORTANT
AND ALLOW ME
TO KEEP MY DREAM ALIVE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MONT HANDLEY, AND I'M
FROM PITTSBURGH, PENNSYLVANIA.
YEAH!
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
I'M THE INVENTOR OF PittMoss,
AND I'M HERE TO OFFER YOU
25% EQUITY
FOR A $600,000 INVESTMENT
IN MY MANUFACTURING COMPANY.
PittMoss IS A SOIL ALTERNATIVE
THAT'S GOING TO GREEN UP
THE LANDSCAPING
AND GARDENING INDUSTRY.
SHARKS, WALK THROUGH
ANY RETAIL GARDEN CENTER,
HOME-IMPROVEMENT STORE,
OR EVEN YOUR LOCAL SUPERMARKET,
AND YOU'RE LIKELY TO SEE
A DISPLAY OF PLANTS.
I KNOW
THOSE PLANTS HOLD AS MUCH
AS 85% PEAT MOSS
IN THOSE CONTAINERS.
PEAT MOSS IS STRIPPED AWAY FROM
DRAINED AND DEGRADED PEAT BOGS
THAT WE ARE DEPLETING,
AND THAT WOULD AID US
IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
IF WE SIMPLY LEFT THEM ALONE.
AND THAT'S WHY
I INVENTED PittMoss.
PittMoss IS MADE
FROM RECYCLED PAPER
AND A SECRET FORMULA
OF ORGANIC ADDITIVES,
AND IT HAS PROVEN ITSELF
TO BE SUPERIOR TO PEAT MOSS
IN EVERY CONCEIVABLE WAY.
WE EVEN GREW THESE PLANTS HERE
IN PittMoss
AND SHIPPED THEM ALL THE WAY
FROM PITTSBURGH FOR YOU.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SAY, SHARKS?
WHO WANTS TO BE
A DIRTY CAPITALIST
AND INVEST IN MY SOIL
ALTERNATIVE CALLED PittMoss?
CAN WE SEE IT?
I HAVE A QUESTION.
ABSOLUTELY.
CAN WE --
JUST A SAMPLE?
HOW DOES THE PRICE COMPARE
TO DIRT -- REGULAR OLD DIRT?
WELL, WE'RE NOT COMPARING
TO DIRT.
AND HOW DOES IT COMPARE
TO PEAT MOSS?
PEAT MOSS IS
A PREMIUM PRODUCT
THAT GREENHOUSES
AND NURSERIES USE,
AND IT SELLS
ON A CUBIC-FOOT BASIS.
PEAT MOSS RANGES
ABOUT $2.50.
AND THIS RANGES
HOW MUCH?
WE MAKE 60% PROFIT
AT $2 A CUBIC FOOT.
SO IT'S 20% CHEAPER?
IT'S ABOUT
15% TO 25% CHEAPER.
AND IT'S GREEN.
WE ACTUALLY CAN SAVE GROWERS 15%
ON THEIR OPERATING COSTS,
BECAUSE IT'S SUPERIOR
TO PEAT MOSS.
THE NATURAL PRODUCT
CARRIES IN PATHOGENS --
WEED SEEDS, MOLD SPORES,
INSECT LARVAE.
OURS IS COMPLETELY UNIFORM,
STERILE PRODUCT.
AND ONE LAST THING --
OUR GROWERS
WHO ARE USING IT RIGHT NOW
REPORT THAT
IT RETAINS MOISTURE LONGER.
IT'S A VERY GOOD THING
FOR THE PLANET.
IF THEY WERE WATERING EVERY DAY
WITH REGULAR PEAT MOSS,
THEY'RE WATERING EVERY OTHER DAY
NOW WITH PittMoss.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR SALES.
OUR SALES.
YEAH.
I'M GONNA BE HONEST WITH YOU.
OUR SALES SUCK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S HONEST.
WE BUILT THIS PLANT IN
NORTH HUNTINGTON, PENNSYLVANIA,
OUTSIDE OF PITTSBURGH,
LAST SUMMER.
I QUIT MY JOB.
I CASHED OUT MY 401(k)s
TO BUY THIS EQUIPMENT.
I COULD NOT FIND INVESTORS
TO HELP ME BUILD MY DREAM,
SO I DID IT MYSELF.
I THOUGHT I'D BE
GIVING THE PRODUCT AWAY
FOR 8 TO 12 MONTHS
BEFORE WE HAD OUR FIRST SALES.
IT TOOK US TWO MONTHS
TO GET OUR FIRST SALES.
THAT SOUNDS GOOD SO FAR.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHERE'S THE BAD?
HE HASN'T GIVEN US
THE TOTAL YET.
THE BAD IS -- OH, $22,000
FOR THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS.
WHY ONLY $22,000?
WHAT'S HOLDING YOU BACK?
WHY DIDN'T THE ORDERS
KEEP COMING?
WE DO HAVE ORDERS.
WE HAVE $168,000
IN SALES AGREEMENTS RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU CAN'T FILL THEM
BECAUSE OF CAPACITY?
WE CANNOT FILL THEM.
WHY?
CAPACITY. WE --
HOW MUCH CAN
THE EXISTING PLANT MAKE?
OH.
ANSWER THAT.
THE EXISTING PLANT
CAN MAKE
ABOUT 200 TONS A YEAR,
AND WE NEED TO --
AND HOW MUCH IS THAT
IN REVENUE?
UM, $60,000.
YOU KNEW GOING IN
THAT THE SIZE OF THE FACTORY
YOU WERE BUILDING
WOULD ONLY PRODUCE $60,000
OF TOP-LINE PRODUCT?
I ONLY BUILT THE FACTORY
TO PROVE MY CONCEPT.
OH, SO THE ENTIRE THING
WAS JUST A PROOF OF CONCEPT.
IN MY MIND, THAT'S WHAT
I BELIEVED I WAS DOING.
WHAT ABOUT THE PATH
OF RESISTANCE TO SELLING IT?
TO CHANGE THE PURCHASE BEHAVIOR
OF GROWERS IS A CHALLENGE.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T
SEE THAT, KEVIN.
WE ACTUALLY SEE GROWERS
WHO HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO LOYALTY
TO PEAT MOSS -- NONE.
I'M GROWING TOMATOES.
I DO $2 MILLION
IN TOMATOES,
AND I USE PEAT MOSS.
YOU COME TO ME AND SAY,
"I FINALLY GOT THE PLANT GOING.
I'VE GOT THE $500,000
FROM MR. WONDERFUL.
I'M READY TO ROCK HERE."
AND THAT PERSON WILL SAY,
"THIS IS GREAT.
I HAVE NO RESISTANCE
TO SWITCHING OVER."
IS THAT TRUE?
WHAT HE'S GONNA DO --
HE'S GONNA GROW MAYBE 10%
OF HIS CROPS IN OUR PRODUCT
TO PROVE THAT IT WORKS.
WHY? BUT YOU --
WHY? 'CAUSE HE'S NERVOUS
ABOUT DOING IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
WOULDN'T YOU BE?
WHAT IS YOUR STRATEGY,
THOUGH?
ARE YOU TRYING
TO SERVICE GREENHOUSES?
ARE YOU TRYING TO SELL THIS
TO THE CONSUMER?
ARE YOU TRYING TO SELL IT
TO FARMERS?
YES.
OR ARE YOU TRYING
TO DO ALL THREE?
WE THINK WE CAN SCALE
BY GOING WITH THE COMMERCIAL
GROWERS FIRST...
COMMERCIAL FIRST.
...AND ACTUALLY BRAND THE PLANTS
SO THAT WE CAN GET INTO
THE RETAIL SPACE
WITH THE PLANTS,
THE PittMoss-GROWN PLANTS.
HOW DO YOU GET
TO THE GREENHOUSES?
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PRODUCT
IS, WHAT ARE YOU GIVING THEM?
WE GIVE THEM
A UNIT OF PRODUCT,
A 50-CUBIC-FOOT UNIT
OF PRODUCT,
AND LET THEM PLAY WITH IT,
WITH ALL THEIR DIFFERENT CROPS
THAT THEY'LL USE --
THEY'LL GROW IN ONE SEASON.
Herjavec: HERE'S WHAT
I REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH IT?
I MEAN,
IT'S SO CREATIVE.
ROBERT, I HAVE BEEN INTERESTED
IN COMMERCIAL GREENHOUSES,
AND DON'T ASK ME WHY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT SINCE I WAS
A LITTLE KID.
WHEN I BOUGHT MY
FIRST GREENHOUSE WHEN
I WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
MY PARENTS DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
I DID IT,
AND MY MOTHER WAS LIKE,
"I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU SOLD A GREENHOUSE
TO A 12-YEAR-OLD BOY."
MY FIRST JOB OUT OF COLLEGE
WAS MANAGING FIVE LOCATIONS
OF A RETAIL NURSERY, AND THAT'S
WHERE I CAME UP WITH THE IDEA.
I TURNED 50 THIS YEAR,
AND I SAID TO MYSELF,
"IF YOU DO NOT DO THIS NOW,
YOU WILL NEVER DO IT."
AND THAT'S WHY I SAID,
"YOU HAVE TO DO THIS."
AND I'M FLYING BACK
TO PITTSBURGH IN TWO DAYS
TO CLOSE A DEAL
WITH BlueTree ALLIED ANGELS.
THEY'RE AN ANGEL
INVESTMENT GROUP.
O'Leary:
HOW MUCH -- WHAT VAL--
'CAUSE YOU PUT A VALUE OF THIS
OF $2.4 MILLION.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND YOU BASICALLY HAVE MARGINAL
SALES -- PRACTICALLY NOTHING.
ACTUALLY, WE HAVE
A CREDIBLE GROUP OF INVESTORS
WHO ARE ACCEPTING
OF THAT VALUATION.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU GONNA
RAISE FROM THEM?
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT WITH THEM
FOR $400,000
IN CONVERTIBLE NOTES.
IN THE PLANT
THAT YOU HAVE NOW...
YES.
...HOW MUCH WILL IT COST
TO MAX OUT YOUR PLANT?
$120,000.
HOW MUCH REVENUE
WILL THAT GENERATE IN ONE YEAR
IF YOU SELL OUT 100% OF IT
AT YOUR LOWEST COST --
TO YOUR
LOWEST-PRICE CUSTOMER?
$1.6 MILLION.
OKAY, SO,
FOR A COST OF $240,000,
YOU CAN HAVE TWO LINES.
RIGHT.
THAT WILL GIVE YOU
AN APPROXIMATE REVENUE CAPACITY
FOR THAT PLANT
OF $3.2 MILLION.
THAT'S CORRECT.
LET ME CLEAR THE FIELD.
I'M SORRY.
I HAVE TO SPEAK.
WAIT, BARBARA, YOU SH--
NO.
I JUST WANT
TO CLEAR THE FIELD.
SURE.
ALL RIGHT.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT,
YOU HAVE $22,000 IN SEVEN MONTHS
IN SALES.
YES.
THAT'S A FACT.
YES, MA'AM.
THAT'S THE ONLY FACT
I SEE HERE.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS CONJECTURE,
PROJECTIONS.
IT'S NOT SEXY.
OKAY.
I'M OUT.
HOW MUCH DO YOU OWN
RIGHT NOW?
I CURRENTLY OWN
70% OF THE BUSINESS.
SO YOU'RE -- YOU'RE GONNA
SELL PAST CONTROL
JUST TO FINANCE
THE FIRST ROUND?
NOT QUITE.
IT'LL BE EQUAL --
NO, HE'S GONNA GET TO 51%.
NOT 51%.
I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
WELL, YOU ARE, 'CAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE MY $625,000,
THEN YOU'RE GONNA BRING IN
ANOTHER $400,000.
RIGHT, SO YOU'RE GETTING
PRETTY DARN CLOSE.
WE'RE GETTING CLOSE.
I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND.
SO, WHAT HE'S SAYING IS,
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO WALK AWAY FROM THE ANGELS
IF YOU GOT A DEAL HERE?
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT,
AND MONT STILL HAS NO OFFERS
FOR HIS PEAT MOSS ALTERNATIVE,
PittMoss.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO WALK AWAY FROM THE ANGELS
IF YOU GOT A DEAL HERE?
I...WOULD PROBABLY
BE WILLING TO DO THAT.
SO, I HAVE TO AGREE
WITH BARB.
I DON'T LIKE THAT YOU ONLY HAVE
$22,000 IN SALES
IN SEVEN MONTHS.
YES.
I THINK
THERE MIGHT BE A PROBLEM
IN THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE
A LONG TIME TO EDUCATE PEOPLE
TO SWITCH OVER.
LORI --
SO IT WORRIES ME
TO INVEST IN YOUR COMPANY,
ON AN UNPROVEN MODEL,
WE DON'T KNOW
IF IT'LL CHANGE PEOPLE OVER,
AND IT KIND OF SEEMS LIKE
AT THE MOMENT,
YOU'RE STRUGGLING
TO DO THAT.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THIS IS NOT A FAD.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN,
BECAUSE THERE ARE ALREADY
GOVERNMENTS AROUND THE WORLD
WHO ARE BANNING THE USE
OF PEAT MOSS IN HORTICULTURE.
KEVIN.
THE UNITED KINGDOM
HAS ALREADY SET VOLUNTARY DATES.
WAIT, WAIT, LET ME -- WAIT,
WAIT, LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT IT.
I'VE GOT AN OFFER.
KEVIN, KEVIN, KEVIN, KEVIN.
LET ME GO.
LET ME MAKE AN OFFER.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE SAYS.
I'M NOT WILLING TO GO IN
ON $600,000 --
JUST DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT IT --
BUT I WANT TO PARTICIPATE,
SO I'M NOT...
DOES ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO GO IN
ON IT? I'LL PUT UP $200,000.
OKAY, LOOK, LOOK,
THERE'S TREMENDOUS VALUE
IN GETTING ONE OR MORE SHARKS
VERSUS YOUR ANGEL INVESTORS.
I THINK YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU
$600,000.
THERE MAY BE OTHER PARTICIPANTS
IN THAT,
BUT I'M WILLING TO MAKE YOU
AN OFFER OF $600,000 FOR 40%.
UM, I THINK YOU JUST
DEVALUED MY VALUATION
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY.
I -- I'M OPEN TO --
WELL, GIVE ME A COUNTER.
I'M INTERESTED IN
YOUR BUSINESS.
I'M OPEN TO A DIFFERENT
VALUATION. SURE.
I MIGHT GO AS HIGH
AS 30%.
I THINK IF YOU GO TO 35%,
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
OKAY, I'LL -- J-- BEFORE --
LET'S GET SOME THINGS ON
THE TABLE, HERE, FIRST.
SO IF YOU LIKE
THE PERCENTAGES, RIGHT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT'S GONNA GET JUICY.
KEVIN AND I HAVE THOUGHT,
FOR SURE.
ROBERT, I DON'T THINK
WE'D HAVE A PROBLEM
IF THE THREE OF US
WENT IN TOGETHER.
UM...
OH, I'M IN.
LET'S GO.
$600,000 FOR 35%
FOR MARK, KEVIN,
AND MYSELF.
I THINK THAT SOUNDS LIKE
A GREAT DEAL.
LET'S DO IT.
DONE.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOING BACK TO THE BURGH!
YEAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
GOOD JOB.
CONGRATULATIONS, MONT.
YEAH. THANK YOU.
YOU REALLY KNOW
YOUR STUFF.
THANKS.
YEAH, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
O'Leary:
VERY INTERESTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS, EVERYONE.
VERY INTERESTING.
Handley: THIS MEANS THAT I CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE A LIVING
BUILDING ON THE DREAM THAT I HAD
FOR 20 YEARS,
[ Voice breaking ] SO THAT'S --
THAT'S A REALLY AMAZING FEELING.
[ SNIFFLES ]